so if we go back to the original concept
it was not only a concept that deals
with a low-carbon economy it deals with
finding the solutions that will make it
possible for the world at large
including all the different parts and
the different kinds of populations to be
able to live decent lives to have a
future for their children and that we
can live in a pattern of development
that means that we are not undermining
our own future by ruining the plan the
planet undermining our environment and
doc biodiversity and so it's true that
in the broader context it's not only a
question of co2 emissions or even low
carbon it is a broader concept social
and environmental concept including
equity including the reality that people
in all parts of the world poor people
today they need to be able to survive
they need to have decent lives and
livelihoods and this is something that
is a common destiny for all of us
whether in the rich or the poor world
now
well I'm basically an optimist I believe
in human ingenuity I believe in
innovation I believe we can do a lot of
what's necessary by doing investment
into research and technology but also
into social awareness of understanding
that not only people living in the
industrial north have you know the
rights at your future safer and more
prosperous life this is a combination of
social understanding and global
understanding and using the methods and
to invest in new technologies and new
ways of doing things in such a way that
we can all survive in a better lifestyle
even than today and that we can overcome
poverty and really get on the track of
sustainable development also in the
poorest countries around the world I so
I am optimist I think the limitations on
general standard of living worldwide are
not going to be in any way dramatic it's
going to be moving forward in a
consistent pattern of using what's known
that can help us into a sustainable
development pattern and to invest in
even more new solutions to help that
happen